el equipo argentino de antropología
forense leaf está explorando la
guarnición militar de campo de mayo en
la provincia de Buenos Aires en este
caso con la asistencia de personal del
ejército durante la última dictadura
militar aquí funcionaron centros
clandestinos de detención Y se cree que
puede haber inhumaciones de personas
desaparecidas en fosas sin marcar lo que
primero hicimos fue un relevamiento de
estos lugares
para poder visualizarlo para ver dónde
estaban y ahora lo que estamos haciendo
es volver a esos puntos y excavarlos
bueno para ver si encontramos algo que
que sea de interés este predio es
inmenso 5000 hectáreas de terreno
diverso mucho de vegetación muy cerrada
para determinar dónde excavar contaron
con la ayuda de una nueva herramienta
que le ha utilizado por primera vez en
este contexto el la edad se trata de un
dispositivo láser que toma medidas con
gran velocidad y precisión montado en un
avión realizó un barrido del predio con
el que luego se elaboraron detallados
mapas de puntos del terreno de campo de
mayo a cargo del procesamiento y
análisis de los datos del slider está
Daniel del cogliano
relevando el terreno desde mil metros de
altura o 1200 metros de altura
superficie de 5000 hectáreas que las las
registramos en un par de horas podemos
luego de meses de trabajo de análisis
detectar depresiones o elevaciones del
terreno
del orden de dos o cinco centímetros
todas estas imágenes son resultado de
ese análisis lo más importante es la
identificación de rasgos específicos en
el terreno como las depresiones
Estos son todos rasgos que pudimos
marcar con el líder como eventuales
lugares de
interés en el terreno el equipo de leaf
use esos puntos para ubicar los lugares
donde excavar
sin el slider esta misma tarea habría
sido descomunal hubiese sido casi
imposible porque tendríamos que haber
caminado durante todo el predio no sé
sellado mucho tiempo se tendrá que haber
hecho un trabajo mucho más Este
detallado en función de ver cómo eran
las depresiones hubiésemos tardado
digamos años tal vez en poder hacerlo
para comparar la escala visitamos este
otro proyecto de leaf en un lote de 30
metros por 40 que el equipo aborda con
estrategias arqueológicas clásicas
durante la última dictadura militar en
este lugar hubo un centro clandestino de
detención aquí funcionaba una comisaría
un destacamento de policía provincial
y la denuncia con el costamos es que en
este patio abrieron la innovación de un
grupo de personas acá decidas a finales
del año 1977
en caso de encontrar restos los envían
al laboratorio de leaf para hacer
analizados estos restos no tienen
relación con la excavación que acabamos
de ver pero cada hallazgo es sometido al
mismo minucioso trabajo de laboratorio
a veces parece algo muy mecánico pero en
realidad
es
una pequeña porción del rompecabezas de
tratar de no solamente identificar a la
persona sino tratar de establecer las
causas de la muerte y que pudo haber
pasado con esa persona con el cuerpo de
esa persona una vez que que fallece en
este laboratorio también se toman
fragmentos de hueso que se envían a otro
centro que extrae el ADN para que se
pueda cotejar con el de eventuales
familiares gracias al uso de técnicas de
ADN se lograron importantes avances para
identificación y restitución como en el
caso de Fernando arándic esta me encanta
esta foto es buenísima es cuando está
haciendo el servicio militar es para dar
respuestas a personas como Fernando que
trabaja el equipo a Antropología forense
en 2010 mediante cotejo de ADN eleaf
confirmó la identidad de los restos de
su padre Raúl araldi que había sido
asesinado en la última dictadura y cuyo
cuerpo había sido enterrado Sin nombre
en un cementerio del Norte del país
el trabajo es impresionante a m
devolvieron
mucha una gran parte de mi vida menos la
posibilidad de sentirme hijo de tener un
padre
de regreso en campo de mayo el equipo
continúa la exploración guiado por la
información del lider esa tecnología les
ofrece un primer pantallazo pero el
trabajo en el terreno es insoslayable y
hasta que no se camina y secaba no hay
certezas
todavía no han encontrado restos humanos
en campo de mayo pero apenas están
comenzando su trabajo